nous sommes au moment où tout a commencé
étions à l'abri nous nous sommes réveillés à 5h30
matin depuis le début de l'explosion, c'est-à-dire encore 24
numéros et de temps en temps nous nous sommes réunis
des explosions quand on a entendu des explosions c'est
ils ont été immédiatement récupérés et évacués vers la pépinière
jardin à proximité
des mesures
être capable de
il y a aussi un diskos propre et c'est ici avec
lunettes mois sexistes kharkov
que j'ai moi-même équipement ils ont simplement
frappé comme un élixir.
mon père
et demander quand cela finira-t-il quand
alors en général c'est fini ce qui va leur arriver
peur et nous avons peur que nous n'ayons rien pour eux
répondre nous ne savons pas ce qui se passera demain
ce qui va nous arriver dans une heure nous avons peur
nous avons peur pour nos enfants, pour nous-mêmes, pour nos familles et
nous avons peur pour nos proches
[musique]